ich habe keine sonne ich muss arbeiten
das muss wieder da noch ein bisschen es
gut danke schön
hallo kinder hallo kinder keine sorge
keine sorge hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne hab ich dich richtig überzeugend
ich möchte mich nicht entschuldigen dass
ich keine videos poste ich weiß nur dass
es doof ist und ich habe so viele ideen
und ich möchte jetzt wieder richtig
loslegen
der sommer gibt mir immer so neuen schub
glaube ich gut gut sommers würde ich
sagen ich wollte sagen dass ich videos
posten werde
da ich jetzt aber erst loslegen muss
wollte ich nicht noch länger warten
lassen und ich habe für euch eine art
wanderwitz wissen denn ich habe für
fantastisch so was gedreht wo ich
selbstbräuner tattoos ausprobieren und
dann habe ich die leute bei einigen dann
gefragt so es ist ein problem wenn ich
das auch mal bei mir dann noch mal hoch
gerade weil sehen wir da noch nicht so
viele und so ok dann bitteschön eine art
wanne will
das ist eigentlich das ist jetzt nicht
rassismus
also ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei
jetzt und es geht los
hallo leute heute habe ich ein ganz
besonderes video für euch
haltet euch fest selbstbräuner tattoos
verbot okay es kann sein dass jetzt viel
zu begeistert von dieser idee bin und es
am ende dann doch echt scheiße wird aber
was müssen wir tun bevor wir wissen ob
was scheiße müssen wir die scheiße
probieren
richtig scheiße probieren okay wir gehen
nicht mehr tief auf die scheiße ein wir
fangen jetzt einfach an ich habe dafür
selbstbräuner an allen variationen
besorgt und schablonen ihr könnt sie
natürlich aber auch selber machen
die fleißigen bienchen schritt 1 macht
euch nackig schritt frei nimmt euch die
peinlichste schablone die ihr gefunden
habt dieses zeichens glaube ich liebe
nehmen als erstes schönes am training
ich bin super für diese prognose
deswegen versuchen wir es jetzt anders
mit einem selbst nicht tuch da nehme ich
jetzt mal das tuch und tupft einfach mal
in der zeit der wir jetzt warten dass
das sich mal zeigt probiere ich jetzt
mit selbst breunings creme und einem
pinsel mir mal ein herz draufzahlen
herbst ich sehe das ja noch nicht mehr
dass das erfüllt
ich muss jetzt noch ein bisschen
trocknen lassen ich hoffe dass man noch
was sieht gleich ich habe gute hoffnung
aber sehen wir bald für euch jetzt
gleich für mich galt sie haben doch von
über scheiß ausprobieren gesprochen oder
ich habe aus schlag bekommen von helfern
kriegt ja hier oben hat eine aussage
macht ihr das britische rote linien
ziehen falls jemand von euch hautarzt
ist und warum es da oben ausschlag
gegeben hat und da unten nicht rufen sie
bitte unter dieser nummer an
was tut man also in so einer situation
man konnte weglaufen oder man stellt
sich dem problem und sagt hey dann mache
ich das eben mit lidschatten darf es
sich nicht bewegen
dabei sollte die bleibend make up
challenge machen wir uns gleich in einem
hallo oder stolz künstler also was haben
wir heute gelernt kinder genau wenn das
leben euch steine in den weg legt dann
baute fast raus und ich habe ja am
anfang gesagt dass es vielleicht der
neue sommertrend 2016 wird ich glaube
tatsächlich dass das hier der
sommertrend 2016 werden kann wenn ihr
noch mehr solcher kreativen videos sehen
wollt dann abonniert den kanal hier lade
ich ihnen dienstag donnerstag und
sonntag ein neues video hoch bis dann
gleich weg
ich wäre es jetzt einmal wenn ihr lust
habt den kanal zu abonnieren macht ist
da kommen viele videos ich koste da drei
videos die woche und ja und einmal die
tv-sendung am freitag wenn ihr noch mehr
von mir sehen wollt wenn dir doch mal
was steht da bleibt hier
hier kommt jetzt wieder mehr versprochen
an ihr versprechen sollte man nichts
oder ich lasse es jetzt einfach you know
me we know it aber bald mit richtig
coolen sachen nein auch nicht wirklich
ich verspreche euch gar nichts bis dann
tschüss